[BEEPING]
SPEAKER: If you're a
data-driven enterprise,
you've likely been met with
an explosion of data growth
in recent years and
need to find the best
way to store all your terabytes
and petabytes at scale.
Google Cloud Storage allows
worldwide storage and retrieval
of any amount of
data at any time.
You can use Google Cloud Storage
for a range of scenarios,
including serving
website content,
storing data for archival
and disaster recovery,
or distributing large
data objects to users
via direct download.
In this hands-on lab, Cloud
Storage Qwik Start Console,
you will learn how to use the
Google Cloud Platform console
to create a storage bucket,
then upload objects,
create folders, and subfolders,
and make those objects publicly
accessible.
Data doesn't just mean rows, and
columns, and numbers anymore.
You may want to store
unstructured data
like messages, documents,
multimedia files, web pages,
and so on.
Whatever your storage
requirements are,
security, availability,
and cost will
be your three considerations.
Cloud Storage aims to meet
all of these requirements.
Next up on our quest
is Cloud IM Qwik Start.
[MUSIC PLAYING]